you
hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane second Kevin McGuire and andrew
pearson here to look back at the biggest
stories of the last seven days would
have been your top stories of the week
the Queen's Speech only the second from
a Conservative government in 23 odd
years and there was hardly anything in
it they shouldn't have put the poor old
queen through it waste of time Kevin
Boris Johnson gone bananas Nigel Farage
talking about a second referendum it
sounded like whining losers mmm well
more on both of those stories in a
second but first that's going to taste
of what the week was all about a
passenger plane flying from Paris to
Egypt disappeared from radar over the
Mediterranean Sea 66 people were on
board the government's legislative
program was lived to Parliament on
Wednesday in the Queen's Speech prison
reform a British bill of rights in a
bill to fight extremism were all
proposed meanwhile a man was arrested at
Buckingham Palace after scaling a
perimeter wall the 41 year old was not
armed two of the 220 girls abducted from
school in Nigeria by Boko Haram two
years ago who've been rescued one Amina
Ali met the country's president after
being found in the sambisa forest with a
four month old baby shadow home
secretary Andy Burnham has launched his
bid to become mayor of Greater
Manchester the former cabinet minister
says Westminster has failed the north
and that he'll promised to tackle the
north-south divide the black bear has
been captured after straying into a city
in southern california Danimal wandered
into Rancho Cucamonga strolling along
streets and climbing trees before it was
shot with a tranquilizer and released
back into the wild and hundreds of
people elsewhere in the united states
reported seeing a huge fireball thought
to be a meteor light up the night sky
footage of the event was caught on a
police dashboard camera in portland
well as we record the show mystery still
surrounds the loss of Egypt air ms 804
and the search for clues is continuing
and the southern shop for families kevin
is just desperate isn't it I'd rather
geologists Richard Osmond you just
become a father a second time he's going
off he's very happy 66 lives have been
lost families are devastated and you and
you kind of just wonder about the horror
on that plane whatever happened but when
you know something is going badly wrong
when you're traveling it's just just
absolutely organ you just hope that it's
something that happened very very
quickly on you mercifully quick yeah
well let's move on to one of the big
stories of the week and this is that the
government reached a compromise with
junior doctors leaders over their bitter
standoff around weekend working and this
follows 10 days of intensive talks and
of course months of angry recriminations
and strikes junior doctors now have to
vote on whether to accept the agreement
skies health and science correspondent
Thomas More reports the British Medical
Association and the government have
agreed a contract that paves the way for
more weekend working the deal will be
put to junior doctors in a ballot in the
coming weeks the dispute had got bogged
down over Saturday pay but under the new
agreement doctors will only get premium
rates after working six weekends in a
calendar year giving the NHS the
financial Headroom to increase basic pay
the junior doctors leader said it was
the best and final way of resolving the
crisis at the heart of this dispute has
been the government's manifesto promise
of seven-day NHS services only possible
if more doctors were rostered to work
weekends according to the Health
Secretary Jeremy Hunt said the agreement
was the biggest change to doctors
contracts in 17 years on his way into
work for a night shift trainee surgeon
Duncan steel like many other doctors was
digesting well the contract would mean
without question it's positive step it's
great that we've been able to start
talking again and made some sensible
changes I think morale in general is
very low and you can see that with the
training applications this year they're
hugely down and lots of people are
already moving to places like Australia
New Zealand the protracted dispute has
politicized a professional where
force the government still has a lot of
work to do to win back the doctors trust
so here's one in all of this as is there
a winner is it the junior doctors I
think patients win when there aren't any
doctors strikes but all if this from the
beginning was really about a lack of
trust between the doctors and Jeremy
Huntley health secretary who handled
dispute incredibly badly acting like an
18th century mill owner in trying to
impose an agreement which wasn't agreed
he was abusing doctors lots of smears
lots of black propaganda and some junior
doctors say they want to reject that
deal well afraid have really got nowhere
to go once their professional negotiator
said this should be I mean under the
fact that they were able to reach a deal
finally that that did show is howdy
Alexander pointed out in the comments
that a negotiated deal was possible yeah
why didn't the health sector get there
she said he had a computer says no
attitude well maybe that's right but in
the end it's the BMA that have blinked
first and why didn't why did they do it
now yes they have establish and actually
doctors are not been getting as much
money as they do as they thought again
why we can pay better overnight pay but
a lower overall pay exactly is what they
want exactly but that's why a lot of
people are suggesting that the doctors
may reject this offer because they think
they've been sold out by their try
remember when Jeremy Hunt said he
wouldn't go to conciliation he wouldn't
go to an independent body well he did he
went to a cast something gladly York
Tori lot haven't yet abolished and they
SAT the two sides together and you work
through the problems you can always get
a solution i've covered industrial
disputes for 30-odd years you have to
have a bit of give and take on both
sides and you got to have some trust and
that trust wasn't there when ya hunt was
stomping all over sssay moved in yet one
and the BMA blinked because i think they
knew publix Apple Inc public support
agree to get any console here's how big
support was beginning to drain away and
the BMA were aware of that and doctors
were to do you think the damage has been
done in terms of reputational damage
anything I talking about well I'm the
demoralization of it we won't work for
when we want junior doctors to be
happier and and to and were out to
improve and it's not going to improve
but this suggestion that they're all as
soon as they've trained they're going to
clear off a broad fine then give paid
back all the money which the taxpayers
paid to
I look hapless hugs taken another knock
he's not having a very good time as
health secretary and of course it's not
good for morale of doctors and you don't
want them taking a deal like they think
is is poor because I'm not going to work
as well but nevertheless it's better
when it we're nearly there when Ellie
there now but you know blinking you know
hunt haven't given a lot of ground okay
let's move on to our gas of the week and
it wasn't a tricky one to pick this week
this was the boss of a security firm who
admitted that he was personally
responsible for leaving the fake bomb in
a Manchester United toilet that led to
last Sunday's match being abandoned
chris reed md of security search
management and solutions limited said he
placed a number of items in the Old
Trafford ground during a training
exercise but left behind an eight-inch
fake long pipe bomb in a men's toilet he
didn't realize he left it behind because
he had a similar one in his bag he's a
complete idiot and and three million
pounds its cost I think you probably
knows that yeah doesn't know but I said
all that hand I still hope Manchester
United which is one of the richest
football clubs in the world don't bill
that this man security come because it
would probably put him out of it let's
just never listen talk to what he said
he has absolutely i said as i said held
his hands up and apologized I have to
take full responsibility for leaving the
training item behind on Wednesday I'm
absolutely devastated that elapsed in my
working protocols as resulted in many
people being disappointed frightened and
inconvenience nothing I can say we
rectify that it's reassuring isn't it
though these these operations are being
carried out less reassuring that they
managed to not spot this on it on a
check last night miss Wright every
clouds got a silver lining clutch had
some strong now but it was the perfect
evacuation what I couldn't get is why
Manchester United want Lee saw that
dummy bomb says it's a dummy bomb if
it's found ring this telephone number
and why they why somebody didn't think
of ringing that number and putting two
two together that they have you made you
know maybe that's a double bluff maybe
never set the ball off who knows that
they now have had the best dress
rehearsal for a terrorist in San anybody
could ever hope for and it went off very
oddly and very well so in a sense maybe
they've got some to thank this show
something about almost fancy dress
a thousand people out of pocket an
inconvenience yep well I think Mountain
United should give should reimburse the
balm and fans they're trained fer ya
hain't afford it right lots of tweeted
suggestions for that Gathol week by the
way Alex Harris tweeted that in don't
forget keep your suggestions coming in
on twitter using the hashtag winner w I
and r is the hashtag now the
government's legislative program for the
next twelve months was set up by the
Queen on Wednesday at the State Opening
of Parliament 21 bills unveiled
including a House of Lords reform and a
shake-up of the prison system feisal
Islam reports Her Majesty herself of
course is above politics these
traditional scenes of our sovereigns
message used by the leaf campaign to
make its arguments about sovereignty the
House of Commons independent celebrated
by the traditional refusal to allow in
the Queen's representative at first but
this is not politics as normal the Lord
High Chancellor Michael Gove handing
over a one nation Queen speech from a
party split two ways the headlines the
PM's social policy legacy my government
will legislate to reform prisons and
courts legislation will be introduced to
prevent radicalization tackle extremism
in all its forms on the way out the
Prime Minister attempting some small
talk with a friend on Europe Jeremy
Corbyn but not much response it had all
the airs and graces of a normal Queen's
Speech but this was a far from
conventional address from her majesty
it's not just because the government
can't afford to offend voters ahead of
the referendum but David Cameron's
finding it difficult enough without that
to pass his legislation
a modest agenda for the nation announced
by Her Majesty today and even that
dependent on the decision made by the
people next month yeah the referendum
really what felt like that was really
overshadowing what what happened didn't
it well that if that Queen speech is a
prisoner of what's happening because the
only thing that's going on at the moment
is the referendum there was all sorts of
bills were capsized such as the
sovereignty bill which was going to be
brought in just to placate Boris Johnson
to stop him going to the lead side the
only interesting thing that came out of
it i thought was Michael goes varying
stuff on prison reform that prisoners
perhaps we'll just be in jail at
weekends and be at home in a week it's a
quite radical for a Tory government to
do that something I'd support actually
but there's very little else in there
really and there's a bit of a waste of
time the Queen going out to live there
wasn't it did seeing it that there
wasn't a huge amount for the opposition
to go at in this Queen speech that a lot
of the bills as as Andrew says the
prison reform what kind of things that
you would actually think we're more
left-leaning yeah all speeding up
adoption and what was new you could have
probably got in one tweet 140 characters
you didn't need the old girl coming out
and agree creating Disney in a democracy
but it is because of the European
referendum on the twenty-third of you
and that is the big moment and in fact
really Cameron is trying to show that he
still got some wind any sales are going
to carry on claims his great social
reform always kind of social reformer in
the mold of a beetle in a workhouse that
when he's always having to go out to
poor people or the disabled but it
really that should have been held back i
think that's queen's speech until after
the referendum and then you know you
might know you'd be Prime Minister if he
loses yeah of course that's what a lot
of people saying will he be the prime
minister to enforce all this legislation
no no because even if it's a narrow
victory for remain his time as Prime
Minister I think will be coming to an
end and can you get an immature anyway
because they are such a small majority
dude well because they're so so little
contentious stuff in there I can't think
there's much that even come on even if
yes so some of the sort of the
anti-terror stuff it's probably because
it could backfire so I think you'll see
a look around on them right let's a time
for our quiz now why has a 23 year old
woman from Florida being in the news
this week at you know at home we'll find
out after the break
you
we can review with me Jane second i'm
joined by kevin maguire associate editor
of The Daily Mirror and Andrew Pierce
consultant editor of The Daily Mail now
before the break we asked why has this
23 year old woman named unknown from
Florida been in the papers or you can
see it's a fishy tale she was bitten by
a two-foot-long baby reef shark who died
as she was trying to get it off her arm
with its teeth still clamped shut
doctors finally managed to prise the
jaws apart and she later buried it yes
scar but though Jesus I quite conscious
about story one with some people said
that her and her friends had been
annoying the shark they can live with it
so possibly the shark was getting its
revenge yeah but also the fact that her
name hasn't been released and I think is
really neutral in this day and age when
I saw that this happened so pictures
being across the whole world but but not
her name and perhaps they should be
targeted by mad conservationists who
think she murdered the shark mad and
conservation confirmed that she was
playing with it might not have been hurt
but anyway the shark has had a burial
right now is it a Christian Bale 31
athletes could be barred from this
year's Olympics in Rio de Janeiro after
their doping samples from the 2008
Beijing Games came back positive in
retest by the International Olympic
Committee the doping results are the
latest scandal to hit international
sport following allegations involving
athletes at the sochi winter olympics
skies Paul Kelso reports faster higher
stronger it's a motto supposed to
inspire athletes to do their best but
for some winning by any means has become
an alternative motto but from Olympic
headquarters in Lausanne an announcement
that suggests the authorities may be
catching up with the cheats from past
games the IOC has retested more than 450
samples from the Beijing Olympics and
revealed the biggest ever Hall of
positive tests from the single games
there were 31 positive tests for drugs
from athletes drawn from six sports and
12 nations as well as the Beijing
samples the IOC is also conducting more
than 250 tests on samples given at the
London Olympics four years ago more
positives are expected and those found
guilty we'll all be banned from the Rio
Olympics with the clock ticking down
to the start of the Rio Olympics the
International Olympic Committee has
described these positive tests as a
powerful strike against the cheats and
they hope the announcement will bolster
the confidence not just of clean athlete
but of the watching sporting public
where the Russian athletes will be there
remains to be seen the track and field
team is currently banned for systematic
doping and Sky News understands that
Russian athletes are among those
targeted by the IOC World Athletics
governing body led by sebastian coe will
decide their fate on june the 17th some
believe the ban must stay even if it
means clean athletes miss out if they're
not cooperating if they're if they're
giving the impression that so many other
athletes are cheating then they
shouldn't be allowed to the game to go
to the games I'd like to see Russia
there but I think they have to prove
that that that they're getting their act
in order and I think they're going to be
up against it in lausanne testing to
prevent cheats from the past profiting
in the future goes on the message is it
eventually the cheats will be caught do
we have any confidence that this will
happen though I mean it seems that
international sport just is it unable to
clean up attacks why is it taking so
long why do they not know about these
cheats why'd it take an eight years to
find out that 30 odd athletes cheated
and potentially summit the London Games
to probably a lot of my Russian ty space
you window if in the past has been
pressured a hoshido keep it keep it
quiet I'm sure some of the scams are
quite elaborate involve the conspiracies
but it was a time you've got one cheat
it was incredible and there's a huge
shock now it's almost you get so many
and you think well that's what they're
doing the sport is so competitive
there's so much money involved in it now
it's a business it's not just about the
bit be versatile be more sheets of a
court are then allowed back in Ben
Johnson of course was allowed to resume
is running career with no success thank
God but what they get caught check them
out for life do you think the medal
should be reassigned yeah its people is
this yeah there should be and there
should be a ceremony where they can have
their national anthem and so they can
get a bit of fossil you're gonna cut the
ribbons off good idea
reassign him here you can read you can
rewrite the history books okay let's
take you on tour choices of top paper
stories for the week at kevin was
starting with you you've picked Boris
he's at Boris Johnson he's going he's
got some apparently wonky claims yeah
brexit back-up boris johnson boobs or
the burgers brussels banana claims said
yeah that's very good alliteration area
but he he was he was claiming that the
EU had banned the sale of bananas in
bunches of more than two or three which
is just a lie and he's become a
liability actually Boris Johnson he goes
around it can get away with the cheering
people up but the moment you scrutinize
a word he says you find out it's
absolute rubbish because our that his
boss has got a lie down the side that
Britain supposedly sends 350 million a
week to Brussels no it doesn't and even
Nigel Farage admits that isn't true and
even Michael has all time this week
coming out and saying that he thought
that the strain of the campaign was
beginning to tell well just remember
michael has a time the man who sat in a
platform with Tony Blair in 1998 was in
1999 say we must join the European
single character not to do so would be
an economic disaster quite enough advice
from michael has a fine thanks aged 83
time to retire dodge the question boris
johnson is becoming a liability for your
side for brexit look he got it Ronnie
with bananas I'm not attempting to
defend it but i still think on paper
they'd rather have him than not have him
annotated Cameron would much rather but
Boris Johnson was on his side than the
leave site any any speech Boris Johnson
gives now on you as a casual
acquaintance with the truth and is
easily to take it a pleat distortion as
usual and read your choice of paper
stories and this is British Airways
which is considering charging for
in-flight meals it's so real to say
about that well she went right off the
didn't she like they changed the the
Union Flag and had that silly squiggle
she covered it with her handkerchief but
one of the real reasons you like King
orga shows because it was a cut above
ryanair and and easyjet but they just
had to succumb to the inevitable it's
only a consultation isn't it very that
their consulting about whether they will
do it they're gonna thicken up badly
yeah it has caused by pure because you
get a sandwich a couple to it's quite
nice sometimes you get a glass wine yeah
no clattering yeah I gonna say it's a
lot of time since he turned right and
down economy with us and he always goes
left the business cuz you've come right
now the food on be a plane's I'm sad to
say I fly a lot on ba is not very good
and if you if you got a reduction in
your ticket and you are gonna have to
buy the food that have to make it better
to sell it to you it's going to come
from waitrose apparently so at least
it's nice food yeah nice up nice out
it's good yes way choice that require
it's a very it's a very good liar back
in it's a very good supermarket I just
find cheaper alternatives Marius man
right Kevin at muirfield gold club this
is voted against accepting female
members i'm not quite sure whether in
2016 or 1960 yeah right in 16 dinosaurs
and they lost the open when the Royal
and Ancient which organizes golf has a
go at you you really know your dinosaurs
near after but they needed a two-thirds
majority and the old duffers didn't
produce it they were moaning about oh
you bring women in it they'll be
complaining about the lunch are these
are bores I'd I wonder why I mean you
have gone there in the past there's a
whole load of female golfers who had to
have a lunch in the kitchen because they
weren't allowed into the goal I wanted
your mother really why don't women want
to join a horrible old club like that
anywhere but it's an auntie it is it is
a principal and David Cameron always
bangs on about labor and segregated
meetin's with their organized by certain
Muslim groups and I agree that's wrong
but it's also wrong you get now in his
day he has spoken out in support of the
open saying that they're not going to be
open there now because I feel you know a
close up big at all but apparently they
don't want to change it or because that
would mean clubs like the Women's
Institute might have to admit men and
yeah let's face it do you want to get
away from men somewhere nickel surgeons
are treated about this saying Scotland
has women leaders in every walk of life
it's 2016 this is simply indefensible
Kathy lette who always has a good line
on such things their biggest handicap
sexism yup she's right yes I certainly
isn't that now Andrew the University of
East Anglia it admits both men and women
but is worried about the health and
safety of its graduates at why in
particular because
the traditional graduation ceremony they
tossed their mortar board in the air and
they're worried on the grounds of elf
and safety but the mortar board might
hit one of the students and cause the
poor darling some damage I think that a
bandit also at a university like in
Leeds I have to say though wasn't this
some hideous American practice that was
imported from the united states any
because i graduated back and mr. dog we
did have mortar boards but there wasn't
there what we never had anything like
that we don't have a big collector throw
and I never had to return mine to the
high place so I wouldn't have thrown it
one but why are they throwing it anyway
they're throwing it away fishin I think
it's a you know we were in the Nestle
I'm no fan is a wealth and safety unlike
McGuire but it isn't an island thing
later I got my degree sent in the poster
couldn't be bothered to go in Dressel
burr like that but the health and safety
executives attacked what they've done
and there's a real health and safety
issue when hundred and forty two people
died a year at work and this is just
ridiculous it's pathetic it is a bit
silly right thank you very much taking
through through the papers what about
your ups and downs Andrew we're starting
with you at carry on I love the
characters coming back I what a joy I
can't remember either way about 24 of
these films they're part of British
cultural history probably know my life
around like a Kenneth Williams saying
into me if they've all got it in for me
fantastic but I just fear we don't have
Kenneth Williams and Barbara winds are
still cakes patty Jake's I know Barbara
wind is not going to be in it apparently
what if she you know they said that she
spent a long time shaking off at image
I'm sure if I what this week me for what
they've discovered the the movie makers
the production has is people like us
after cash so we'll go and see films
from the genre you watched as kids but I
saw the dads army film it was okay but
it way it was a pale imitation of this
is gonna be a bit more socially aware
they're gonna tackle things like NHS
funding and instead of Hattie Jake's
they've got a butch game matron oh yes
climb it is of it but they should i
pluck time to change and i won't work I
mean you butch it up I'm sorry
as it was awkward and that wrong and we
loved it too belonged Andris dilandau so
I give a warm you up but you Andrea
sending down this week greggs and it's a
previous chance of George Osborne's
favorite shop of course we as we all
know humiliated after his citypass
Suzette's but because it changes in the
high street shops like Greg's are gonna
have to have a Luke's if they're serving
food customers can have W it's always
going to do is put up the cost of their
past is no it's because they have cafes
now don't know if you've got a greasy
spoon next door they needed a tie so why
should Greg I'm pledge chair I like it I
go by the grave past I go to a great
greasy spoon and so they do not have a
loop they matter if you was gonna put
the cost you if you ask you when i use
one they gotta let you yeah absolutely
so we're sending Greg's down you are
sending up there Kevin and one of my
favorite stories of the week this is
collin de and Sally Smith gorgeous all
blessed if I getting married 44 years
after getting together they've both been
married before he was a lip lorry driver
she worked in the local social club in
Leeds you know the met over the bar as
it were but they've decided now in their
eighties they're gonna get mine it's
just nice it's love burns eternal you
get there in the end they've got four
children 13 grandchildren nine
great-grandchildren I didn't see the
radiant to it's fantastic that they had
their reception back in the social tarts
it's just gorgeous makes me go all teary
right so sending them up but you are
sending down at a letter he's saying how
how much the the writer dislikes tuition
fees education should be free and here
is it from George Osborne 2003 and MPs
it was very unfair it was very unfair
when labeled putting up fees i remember
opposing that increase in fees to 3000
he has put him up a 9000 he's now gonna
let them go up higher than that and he's
taken away maintenance grants for kids
from the poorest homes who might not go
at universe is a reason why I hypocrite
well the government says the economic
situation has changed and that they will
not be revising their plans cause a lot
of Mirth this week though on through sir
so we're sending down George Osborne and
his letter back to the nineties thank
you both very much don't forget keep
sending us your nominations who you
would like to send up and down using the
hashtag WI and
winner and will try and include them in
the show thank you for joining us for
our review of the week we'll be back
with much more next week but for now
it's goodbye from them goodbye all right
and it's goodbye from me goodbye